-Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi. -Welcome back to the show.
It is so great to see you.
-I haven't seen you since, like, the pandemic.
-I know. -That was a thing.
-We have a -- That was totally a thing.
I have so many questions. -Okay.
-First of all, I know you're an Eagles fan.
-Well, I'm a Patriots fan. I'm from Massachusetts.
But my side chick is the Eagles 'cause I went to school
in Philly and my husband is a Philly fan.
-Oh. -Yes.
-Your side piece?
-My side piece are the Iggles, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah. And where did you watch the game?
-Well, unfortunately, I was on the airplane coming here.
-Oh. -And the first half was great.
I felt really good about the first half actually.
-Oh, yeah. -And then we were coming in
for a landing, like, right as we were counting down
to the halftime, and I was like, "God dang it.
This plane is going to land
right as Rihanna is coming out on stage."
And, Jimmy, a Rihanna miracle happened!
We landed -- -Delay.
-"Your gate is -- There's a plane at the gate."
-Yeah. The gate took off.
-"We got to sit here for 15 minutes."
-The gate left. The gate is in Pittsburgh.
-And it was, like, we just -- we got to sit here for 15 minutes,
and I got to watch the whole Rihanna halftime show.
-Yeah! So it worked out okay.
-It was a Rihanna miracle. Yeah. -And then you unboarded.
And then you didn't see the end.
-I missed -- No, I saw the end in the hotel last night.
-Oh. -And, yeah, that wasn't great.
-Yeah. But you're here tonight. And thank you --
-I mean, congrats to the Chiefs, by the way.
-Yeah, congrats to the Chiefs. -Congrats to the Chiefs.
-Thank you for coming all the way here and doing our show.
We appreciate this. It's also kicking off Perm Week.
-Ah, yeah. -It's a big deal.
Everyone's talking about it.
-By the way, that guy -- He looks amazing!
-He looks fantastic, right? Yeah.
But I asked you if you ever had a perm.
-Ugh. Yeah.
-And you were nice enough to give us this photo.
You did have a perm.
-Well, technically -- So, what's amazing is --
-Everyone went, "Oh."
-Yeah. -How cute.
-You guys didn't think that I was really
gonna show up with that.
That's actually just my natural hair, Jimmy.
-Is it really? -Yeah. I didn't even perm that.
I thought that if I got a perm that I would get, like,
I don't know, like, beautiful model curls or something.
-Yeah. -And so I did a perm
on top of that -- on top of that hair.
-How can you perm this hair? -Correct.
It's -- What ended up happening is --
-It straightened it.
-It shrunk onto my head into little curls
and I looked like my Grammy.
-Aww. See?
-Like, she went every week and had, like, her little perm done.
And that's -- Yeah, there's not a lot of photos of that.
I refused to get that photographed.
-Did this little girl ever think she's going to go on
to act and direct and -- -First of all,
this little girl, when this photo was taken,
that it would be shown on the effing "Tonight Show"
is crazy to me!
-Come on. Isn't that cool? -Come on!
-Come on, bud. -That girl had no idea.
-Look at what you're doing. -I don't know.
-I want to talk about your movie.
Let me just tell you something. This came out.
I go -- "Cocaine Bear" is trending on Twitter.
I go, "What in the world is 'Cocaine Bear'"?
The trailer for your movie.
-Yeah. -Exploded.
Number-one trend on Twitter.
Everyone's talking about this amazing trailer.
The movie is hilarious. -Thank you.
-It's based on a semi-true story.
-Inspired by a true story. -Inspired by a true story.
-Yes, yes. -Gosh, it's funny, by the way.
-Thank you so much. Yeah, it's a true story.
There was a drug runner in the 1980s,
and his M.O. was that he would drop drugs
out of a low-flying plane for people to pick up on the ground.
And this one night, the drug run goes wrong.
He drops the drugs into the woods,
and a bear gets into the drugs.
This all happened in real life. -Yeah.
-And they never recovered any of the drugs.
But what they found months later
was an OD'd bear in the woods... -Yeah.
-...who had eaten, like, 70 pounds of cocaine.
And so this movie imagines what would have happened
in the hours after that bear first found the bag.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-So it's a bear -- it's a bear on a cocaine bender.
-It's a bear on a bender. -A bear on cocaine.
-Yeah. -It's insanity.
It is complete insanity what happens.
People hiking in the woods, and they meet up with Cocaine Bear.
It's a -- The CGI is amazing. -Thank you.
-I'm assuming a lot of it's --
-It's all -- There was no real bear.
-Yeah. -But I get asked a lot about
what it was like to work with a real bear.
And I really am proud of that.
Because that was the goal, to create a photorealistic --
-You did a great job. -I wanted it to seem like
it was a documentary, Jimmy, of a bear...
-Yeah. --...doing cocaine, you know?
-I love how much money went into this "Cocaine Bear."
-I mean, it's like a Marvel movie, but a giant Cocaine Bear.
Yeah. -Truly. Truly.
-This is -- You brought -- You were nice enough to bring
a behind-the-scenes -- -Oh, yeah.
-One of the actors? -That's Allan Henry.
He's our bear performer.
So, this guy trained under Andy Serkis,
who did "Planet of the Apes."
He walks as a quadruped on all fours
on these, like, special -- Like, anybody would --
You'd blow your back out in two seconds.
-Oh, of course. -It takes a lot of training
to actually be able to do this work.
This is -- You know, so, those are the fake eyes
and the eyeline and everything for the actors.
-So the actors would see that... -Exactly.
-So we would all -- -...coming after them.
-We would see that -- coming after them.
He's a stunt performer, as well,
so he can really attack and throw people around.
You've seen the movie. Things happen.
-Things happen in the first 30 seconds of this movie.
Oh, here's another.
This one is actually just a fake real head.
-Well, so, this head -- That's our real --
That is what our bear looks like.
Cokie. We call the bear Cokie.
And Cokie -- -Cokie the Bear.
-Cokie. -Of course, Cokie, yeah.
-So, Cokie -- These nice gentlemen
would sort of walk around with Cokie
as, like, a lighting reference.
And now that head is in my house.
It's in my office. -Wow.
-And recently a repair guy came over and walked in there,
turned the light on, and lost his mind.
-He's like, "Aah!
You got to tell me if there's a bear head in here."
-Came in. He's like, "That really -- What is that thing?"
"Oh." -Yeah, it's Cokie.
-"We made this movie. That's Cokie."
-"We made a movie called 'Cocaine Bear.'" Yeah.
I want to show a clip.
Here's a look at a scene from "Cocaine Bear."
Check this out.
-[ Panting ]
Where is it?!
♪♪
-Hey!
-[ Grunting ]
-What should I do?!
♪♪
-Ohh!
Aah! Oh, oh, oh!
Ohh. There's something wrong with it.
-Yeah, I told you there was.
-Why is it acting like this?
Did you feed it cocaine?!
-No. But you're safe.
Bears can't climb trees.
-Of course they can!
-Then why are you up here?
♪♪
-[ Whimpering ]
-Elizabeth Banks, everyone.
"Cocaine Bear" is in theaters February 24th.
Kelsey Grammer joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.